I have to say possible to this movie
y'all is just nominated for an oscar but
it's literally played in my house more
than any other movie right now my kids
are obsessed with it do you get this
everywhere you go now yes yeah I mean I
didn't know I was going to be the most
famous for becoming a cat I know you're
not the most English of that but for my
six-year-old son maybe yeah yeah yes yes
freak out softballs I know they love he
does the dance everything I swear to you
watches all the time it was such a
surprise because we did it 10 years ago
oh my gosh are you serious yeah this is
the sequel and we thought it was not
gonna happen thank God that cats don't
get wrinkles
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]